seven million American men are outside
of labor force it's a problem we have to
address so it used to be that virtually
all men between 25 and 55 work but now
we're down to about 88 percent it means
seven million American men are outside
the labor force which may be think what
if we got those men back into work how
would we do it so the question is what
causes so many men especially less
educated and to drop out of the
workforce probably the biggest factor is
that a generation two ago these men
faced good-paying manufacturing jobs but
most of those jobs have disappeared and
if they remain they pay much less than
they used to
they are either going to find low-wage
jobs available but very unattractive or
the jobs themselves won't be available
because they're living in depressed
communities work with so much of the
employment has disappeared
a lot of these men are now on some kind
of public benefit program now these
programs do a lot of good but the
downside of this program is that they
can discourage work effort in addition a
large fraction of them have opioid
dependencies a lot of them will not be
able to pass a drug testing to be able
to take a job there is a quite large
population of mandus with criminal
records employers are very reluctant to
hire these men and on top of that a lot
of these men have children of who they
don't have custody a lot of these men
fall behind in their child support
payments once they are in arrears the
tax rates on their earnings are very
high and they have strong incentives to
disappear from the formal labor market
they might work off the books for cash
it is critical from the standpoint of
construction manufacturing other heavy
industries that we get American workers
who are sitting on the sidelines back
into gainful employment
we need hundreds of thousands of new
construction workers to address a
housing shortage of where are we going
to get those workers if you talk to
those who know the construction sector
they will tell you we are already using
every available worker
so it's one thing to say to men you need
to go back to work but then you have to
actually create jobs for them to go to
men who have only a high school diploma
or even less than that simply don't have
the skills that employers value we want
to be improving the skills that these
men bring to the labor market and
there's a few different ways of doing
that one answer is what we call sector
based training industry representatives
come together with community colleges to
create training programs and curricula
to train workers for those jobs that are
in fact available the other approach
that we have a lot of confidence in is
apprenticeship in these cases they're
being paid while they're training and
they can see the direct relevance of the
training to the work and employers like
it - because you're training the worker
exactly for the skills that the employer
needs
for those who can find jobs we favor
some expansion of tax credits paid to
the workers to make those jobs more
attractive the best example we have that
is something called the Earned Income
Tax Credit one other way to increase
labor force participation among is to
help those who are non-custodial parents
both work and pay child support by
supplementing their wages with an Earned
Income Tax Credit it rewards them for
working and supporting their family
raising men skills is not the only issue
we face we also have to address public
assistance programs that encourage men
to stay out of labor force and not work
and the way we do that is we make those
programs say to the applicants for them
how can we help you get a job one of
those programs is the consent program
which does a lot in America reduce
hunger and lower poverty but it also has
an increasing number of adults for
receiving food stamps and our reporting
no earning and they're not disabled and
they're not elderly and they're not
children
they're able-bodied adults and could be
in the workforce and art in order to
make these assistance programs more
effective at moving people into work
there has to be an understanding between
the agency and the recipient but the
recipient needs to do something to
advance their economic situation they
need to move toward work and if they
don't have to be contemplated
one project that's going on right now in
Baltimore Maryland is a redevelopment of
Port Covington neighborhood the city of
Baltimore is putting in five hundred and
thirty-five million dollars or the tax
subsidies a development group it's
matching those funds but in order to get
the tax subsidies the developers have
committed that 30% of the new jobs
created will go to residents of the city
of Baltimore some of those jobs need to
be reserved
currently out of course the reality of
our labor market is that over the last
40 or 50 years we've seen a dramatic
shift where jobs involving heavy
industry work have been offshored we've
experienced the industrialization and
the president made a commitment during
his campaign to bring some of those jobs
back members of the House and Senate
doesn't it ought to consider the
creation of a requirement for Community
Benefit greens that entities receiving
federal tax subsidies would have to set
aside a certain number of jobs to be
created for people who have exhausted
their unemployment benefits and present
to the government their plan for
bringing these people back into the
labor force it's not just the economy
that will be strengthened by getting
them back into work it's the men
themselves because when they're working
they're much less likely to be poor
they're much less likely to be unhealthy
and they're much more likely to be
strong providers for their families and
their children a good way to illustrate
the inadequacy of our public assistance
programs is when I went out and talked
to people who are receiving benefits I
talked to a man who said that program is
very good at getting me an EBT card but
it does nothing to get me a job